[Music]
with a growing number of americans
getting vaccinated
the cdc has released new guidelines
about
when it is and isn't safe to be inside
with others
those rules can be a little difficult to
remember but
luckily an r b group called silk press
has come out of retirement
with a new song to help us all keep it
straight take a look
dr sexy's cdc helpline i know figuring
out who can hang out with who can be
confusing
and baby i'm here to help i have some
questions
i'm vaccinated are you vaccinated i'm
vaccinated
do you live alone or is everyone in your
household
also vaccinated you know it well
i gotta know oh
i wanna hang indoors with you
i'm vaccinated too can we hang
yeah we can hang you get to my house
i gotta ass can you take off your
mask when we hang that's a sure thing
i wanna cooking food it's gonna be
delish i wanna serve you up some of the
smelliest fish i wanna watch
old ass movies with you and tell you
what each character's about to do
uh you know what actually i'm busy that
night
dr sexy dr sexy i have some questions
all right let me have it
unvaccinated i live alone
i'm asking you on this phone can we hang
[Music]
i'm gonna go through all your stuff i
got a lot of problems and i'll bring
them up
we can conversate but i'm not too bright
i'm bringing my cat and she loves to
bite you know
i'm actually trying to ease back into
dating i just got out of it
bye-bye what
unvaccinated and i want to chill
and i think you fit the bill can we hang
i hope we can hang on
i want you to see my face can we take a
mass off in this place
when we hang that's a sure thing
[Music]
i wanna have some fun i wanna treat you
right i wanna get to know you
all through the night i wanna lay you
down in my bed
as soon as i give my grandma her meds no
no nope nope we can't sorry
[Music]
there's no take two of these and call me
in the morning
i'm out of here this is
[Music]
you